do you pray with me
Oh God may the words of my mouth and the
meditations of each of our hearts be
acceptable in your sight
you are our rock and our Redeemer amen
case you haven't noticed we are in a
campaign season here in Connecticut and
the sport of wrestling has played a more
prominent role than perhaps ever before
but instead of talking about wrestling
as a major entertainment business I'd
like to talk about it as a way of being
faithful as Christians just so we don't
get these to confuse the professional
sport and the spiritual practice I'm
going to talk about it more frequently
this morning as struggling struggling is
a more appealing word for me at least I
can't stand one moment of violence on TV
and struggling it's something that most
of us experienced at some point in our
lives regardless of our athletic
abilities how is struggling a spiritual
practice that can be helpful to
Christians we take as our example this
morning Jacob the story in the book of
Genesis which Ron just read in which
Jacob encounters a figure in the night
and the two wrestle until it is almost
morning
we don't know many of the details but we
do know that Jacob leading up to this
mysterious encounter had been traveling
with his whole family traveling toward
his brother who he had not seen in years
this brother Esau whom Jacob wronged by
stealing their father's blessing this
brother who vowed to kill Jacob this
brother who was coming toward Jacob with
400 men Jacob was wrestling long before
his encounter with this stranger in the
night and then suddenly someone appears
and Jacob is terrified and has to
send himself we never know if Jacob
first assumes that this is his brother
we don't know if the two exchanged words
during the long nights struggle but as
the struggle is coming to an end
Jacob reveals his preoccupation his
motivation to endure this long night of
wrestling I will not let you go until
you bless me he says Jacob's father's
blessing which he stole from his brother
Esau was now a burden of guilt and the
blessings he had received from God
between men and now were impossible for
him to accept because he had done so
much wrong he wanted a new blessing a
real one turns out that Jacob had been
wrestling with God that night in some
form and the blessing is given just as
morning is breaking jacob is given a new
name it is Israel which means wrestles
with God
of course Jacob doesn't leave this scene
unchanged in other ways either he is
given a new name that sign of God's
blessing but he is also given a limp
late in the struggle Jacob was winning
and his opponent struck him in the hip
and put it out of joint
so Jacob leaves this place exhausted
from the long nights struggle I'm sure
as well as blessed and changed
I have fan on the sidelines of such
wrestling matches you have to these
intense spiritual struggles I think of a
young guy preparing to come out to his
parents as gay
he has already been struggling a long
time alone coming to terms with his
identity struggling to tell a friend
struggling with his church's traditional
teachings and now anticipating a
struggle as he shares with
his parents yet somehow he wants the
struggle he needs the struggle because
he's so badly wants the blessing of his
parents and I think of a young couple
finally expecting a child after many
years of hoping only to struggle through
miscarriage and heartbreak they wrestle
with God trying to form words to express
their disappointment and sadness and
anger it is a long night perhaps a whole
season of struggling they so badly want
a blessing from God if not a child then
the blessing of enough strength to
endure this kind of pain I think of the
33 Chilean miners trapped underground
for weeks and weeks and I have to wonder
what kind of wrestling they did how do
you honestly talk to God about life and
death about the small annoying things
and the big cosmic questions when you
are literally living in a dark night of
the soul for so long in a miracle of
technology we got to watch as they
received blessings first a tiny
connection with the world above ground
through that small tube in exchange of
food and letters and then this week
watching as one by one they were reborn
above-ground alive miraculously more
than alive
it seems our spiritual struggles often
parallel Jacob's wrestling in the night
we emerge exhausted from all the
struggling and yet we struggle for a
blessing and we emerge from the struggle
changed our gospel story today also
tells of a struggle a struggle of
endurance by a widow who so believed she
deserved justice that she approached a
judge over and over and over again
defying all of the power structures in
that society approaching a judge who
could care less really
but she finally wore him down he finally
granted her justice just so she would
stop bothering him our persistence our
pesky nests is not the point of this
parable Luke emphasizes that God is not
like the mean judge instead Jesus says
God will grant justice God will not
delay
Jesus urges us then to pray day and
night and God will quickly answer these
prayers yet we know our spiritual
struggles continue and I'm afraid that
we rarely understand these struggles to
be faithful more often I hear people
talk about spiritual struggles as a sign
of weakness and blame the bad things
happening in their lives to a lack of
prayer a lack of persistence not praying
enough or in the right ways so where
does this story of Jacob wrestling all
night long for a blessing meet the
promise in Luke that God will come
quickly and answer us well hopefully
these stories meet in our lives these
stories meet when we pray to Jesus and
don't see fast results when we struggle
with the tough realities of our lives
wondering if blessing will ever ever
come and yet I am convinced that
struggling with God is one way of being
faithful when Jesus invites us to pray
he asks us to pray honestly and if we
are being honest with God we've got to
struggle with God sometimes struggling
prayers usually begin with the question
why God why is this happening
God why isn't this happening Jesus why
aren't you Jesus why haven't you
and then sometimes these struggle
prayers run out of words
maybe Jacobs wrestling story doesn't
report words during the night because
there weren't any the two just had to
wrestle
until finally Jacob could name what he
really wanted a blessing from God
struggling with God is faithful work but
it is still an awful lot of work and yet
it is part of life so don't hide your
struggles from God
don't edit the struggles out of your
prayers God wants to share in these
struggles especially on days when we
celebrate communion like today we
remember that God invites us all to
bring our struggles to this table even
if those struggles are about God God can
handle it the way to this table is paved
by struggle Jesus gathered a table that
night on the night in which he was
betrayed talk about struggle the
beginning of Jesus struggle from life to
the grave and back to life again this is
a table that celebrates Jesus victory in
the struggle from life to death and back
to life this is a table that represents
God's welcome to each one of us who
struggle for justice here we receive a
meal of blessing the blessing of
nourishment after a long night of
wrestling the blessing of God's
community gathered and the promise that
we will never leave this table quite the
same you who struggle rest here for a
moment
receive abundant blessing be changed
amen